من بين كمان الاشياء الكثير من الناس
مهتمين انه يعرفوا اكثر عنها طبعا الاميره
رجوى خلينا نتكلم عن الاميره رجوه هي من
مواليد الرياض من مواليد سنه 94 والدها هو
خالد بن مساعد بن سيف بن عبد العزيز السيف
والدتها هي عزه بنت نايف بن عبد العزيز
احمد السديري وهي الشقيقه الصغرى لفيصل
ونايف ودانا وال سيف بتعود اصولهم لمنطقه
سدير وهي منطقه تاريخيه في نجد وسط
السعوديه رجوى حاصله على بكالوريوس في
الهندسه المعماريه من جامعه سيركلز في
نيويورك وبتحمل درجه تخصص مهني في
الاتصالات المرئيه من معهد الازياء
للتصميم والتجاره في امريكا رجوى بتتكلم
اللغتين الانجليزيه والفرنسيه ومن
هواياتها الرسم وركوب الخير وانتشر
للاميره رجوه على الانترنت صور من طفولتها
تم تداولها بشكل واسع خلينا نشوفها
امس كان في كمان مادبه عشاء بدعوه من
الملك عبد الله الثاني لاربعه الاف شخص من
الاردنيين في مضارب بني هاشم اسمها الاجره
وهي بيعملوها اهل العريس وتخللتها عروض
تراثيه شملت كل اطياف المجتمع الاردني
والقى الملك عبدالله كلمه كانت مؤثره
للحضور والوليه العهد اللي كان لابس زي
التراث الاردني القديم مع الشماغ الاحمر
خلينا كمان والملك ايضا نذكر مشاهدينا ان
الملك اهدى الامير الحسين سيف من التراث
الاردني العريق واهداء الحاضرين مسبحه
مكتوب عليها وجعلنا بينكم موده ورحمه
موصوله بقطعه معدنيه عليها اسم الامير
الحسين
وزوجه الاميره رجوى
وكانت امانه عمان اعلنت عن استكمال كل
الاستعدادات للفرح من تزيين الشوارع
وتعبيد للطرقات وتجهيز الاماكن اللي رح
يوقفوا فيها الناس علشان يتفرجوا على موكب
الزفاف اللي هو طبعا الموكب الملكي الاحمر
اللي تكلمت عنه مفصلا في هذه الحلقه وحتى
في حلقتنا يوم امس